[музика]
вітаємо це програма У фокусі Європа
яллара бабалола Вітаю вас із Новим роком
і Ласкаво просимо на програму надія на
новий початок Це мрія Яка підштовхує
мігрантів шукати кращої долі тут у
Європі кількість біженців які прибувають
сюди різко зросла порівняно з минулим
роком кількість заявок на отримання
притулку в ЄС досягла найвищого
показника із 2015 року на півночі Італії
рідне місто Франческо чи баті трієсто
стало популярним місцем для біженців які
шукають притулку він готовий прийняти їх
надати інформацію та гарячу їжу часто
першу за кілька днів багато зміг грантів
нещодавно завершили важку подорож пішки
часто перетинаючи кордони нелегально
Вони тікають так званим
західноалканським маршрутом який
зазвичай починається в Туреччині і веде
через північну Італію там на них часто
чекає не надто теплий прийом Надії
багатьох мігра біженців розбиваються
вщент коли Вони залишаються на вулиці
напризволяще
за залізничним вокзалом у трієсті
холодно серед руїн старовинного
зерносховища Ізмаїл показує групі
молодих людей де вони можуть
переночувати Ізмаїл родом із Пакистану
Він живий і працює в портовому місті вже
багато років але він ніколи не бачив
такої кількості людей які перебувають до
Італії по балканському маршруту
знаходиться майже 50 осіб
хтось хоче продовжити подорож на північ
хтось попросив притулку в Італії вони
тут Тому що у приймальному центрі немає
вільних місць
дехто провів серед руїн уже три місяці
коли почало холоднішати збудували ці
бараки
18-річний амер та його друзі знаходяться
тут уже кілька тижнів амер розповідає
ізмаїлу Що вони виїхали з Пакистану
більше трьох років тому
перетнули Іран і опинилися в Туреччині
їм знадобилося кілька спроб щоб
нелегально перейти кордон і потрапити до
Європи
його постійно відправляли назад до
Туреччини 14 разів із Греції і 5 разів
із Болгарії
вони виходять зі свого притулку і
прямують нап’ятца де ла Ліберта площу
Свободи саме туди вони вперше прибули
якихось з арфатом
1-2 місяці в Сербії 3-4 місяці у Боснії
а потім я приїхав сюди
було дуже важко немає ніяких центрів для
іноземців ми просто йшли пішки так
у 2021 році до портового міста прибуло
близько 4 тисяч мігрантів та біженців у
2022 році тільки за жовтень і листопад
приїхало близько 5 тисяч Франческо
чіабацій та волонтера асоціації лінія
домбра надають їм одяги інформацію про
їхні права та гарячу їжу
щодня ми замовляємо від 15 до 40
смажених курей залежно від ситуації
ми забезпечуємо їжею 30-40 осіб на день
буває що і 120 рекорд був улітку 174
людини за один день
Франческо каже що держава та міська
Влада мало Чим допомагають
ми приходимо сюди допомагати щодня
протягом трьох із половиною років кілька
простих громадян
леді байдуже хоча це її обов'язок знайти
біженця місце для проживання
Багато з них подали прохання про надання
притулку і мають право на житло але вони
досі його не отримують
мер відкидається звинувачення Він каже
що багато чого зробив за 16 років
перебування на посаді але він відкинув
план створення житла для 80 осіб
заявивши що це не входить в обов'язки
міста в Італії Лише кілька політиків
готові виступити на захист біженців
якщо створює житло для якоїсь кількості
біженців їх буде пробувати все більше і
більше ось у чому проблема
я нагадаю що це не наш відповідальність
афектів
перфектура повинна відкрити порожні
військові казарми і надати місце для цих
нещасних душ
щасливчики знаходять притулок у цьому
колишньому скаутському будинку але він
вже безнадійно переповнений навіть не
опалювальні намети центру первинного
прийому не забезпечують достатньо місця
для всіх біженців як розповідає нам
давіде піціоні з організації ICS
ми знаходимось дуже близько до
словенського кордону тому центри прийому
такий переповнений
зазвичай люди приїжджають і перебувають
там недовго а потім міг розподіляють в
іншу частину Італії для процесу
інтеграції
але зараз це не працює не вистачає місць
працює неподалік від площі Свободи
біженці можуть погрітися в цьому денному
центрі на верхньому поверсі є місця для
ночівлі
наших двадцяти ліжок зовсім недостатньо
якщо подумати про сотні людей яких ми
бачимо щодня і всі вони чекають на місце
у пункті тимчасового розміщення
ми можемо запропонувати найвразливішим
безпечне місце для ночівлі
але на Амира та його друзів чекає ще
одна холодна трізька ніч серед сміття та
картонних коробок
українці також борються з холодною і
гіркою Зимою в той час як війна вирує по
всій країні
російські атаки на об'єкти критичної
інфраструктури не припинялися протягом
Різдва та Нового року тепло та
електроенергія в Україні подаються з
перебоями це стосується І місць далеко
від лінії фронту таких як столиця київ
лікарні Тут також відчувають на собі
вплив війни Олег Корнійчук докладає всіх
зусиль щоб його відділення інтенсивної
терапії працювало і надавало медичну
допомогу своїм пацієнтам його головне
завдання захистити тендітних немовлят та
передчасно народжених дітей які
знаходяться у його палаці від насильства
що коїться навкруги
лікар неонатолог Олег Корнійчук
приїжджає на роботу в цю дитячу лікарню
у Києві Він завжди трохи хвилюється адже
тут постійно вимикають світло разом із
командою він виходжує недоношених дітей
та новонароджених і серйозними
ускладненнями у цьому відділенні
інтенсивної терапії більшість немовлят
потребують апаратів штучної вентиляції
легенів та інших технологій які працюють
на електриці
дорослих діти на відміну від дорослих не
можуть самостійно виробляти достатню
кількість тепла З певних анатомічних
причин і соответственно даже какой
области відповідно Навіть якби ми певний
час дихали замість дітей ручним способом
в результаті це все одно призвело до
смерті
у лікарнях насправді є підстраховка на
випадок відключення електроенергії але
цей кабель веде до дизельних генераторів
які він дістав власноруч російське
вторгнення змусило весь персонал лікарні
працювати у кризовому режимі
знаєте Це як у фільмі про майбутнє
Армагедон якась нескінченна зима але
потім все стало Трохи краще енергетики
багато чого відремонтували
у нас з'явилась надія що можливо на
цьому все і закінчиться
за кілька кілометрів від центру міста
цей стоматологічний кабінет тут теж
доводиться стикатися з частими і
непередбачуваними відключеннями
електроенергії
світло це зараз найменше з наших проблем
люди гинуть на війні
є світло чи немає Ну перечекаємо дві-три
години нічого страшного аби тільки всі
були здорові
в цьому пацієнту пощастило і він отримав
свою пломбу напередодні молодий солдат
прийшов із зубним болем і саме тоді
вимкнули світло
сиділи чекали і навіть пацієнт насильно
засмутився бо він знає що йому треба
зробити цю роботу Так як він нам сказав
що через тиждень відправляється на фронт
тому ми мали йому зробити все
максимально швидко Ольга щетиніна працює
стоматологіною багато років до ситуації
що склалася ставиться спокійно
якщо на роботі немає світла Ми не їдемо
чого нам сюди приїжджати ми сидимо вдома
всією сім'єю
жити на 16-му поверсі проблема адже
немає світла немає ліфта
у чоловіка Ольги Олександра хворих серце
і він не може підійматися сходами Ця
зима була для них важкою навіть
приготувати їжу буває складно
коли є світло підігріваємо все одразу і
перша і друга і компот якщо немає світла
А мені потрібно готувати я можу готувати
вночі
вночі завжди є світло з 11-12 години і
до третьої ночі завжди є світло
людям тут доводиться виживати
уряд встановив тисячі опалювальних
наметів по всій країні які називають
пунктами незламності це місця де можна
відпочити випити гарячого чаю зігрітися
та зарядити телефони
у відділенні інтенсивної терапії
новонароджених Олег Корнійчук доглядає
за своїми маленькими пацієнтами це
справа його життя
до Німеччини
там живуть мої родичі вже понад 35 років
там знаходиться моя сім'я яка провела
півтора місяці в окупації під Києвом
але немає навіть думок таких виїхати
тому що хто подбає про цих дітей які
потребують твоєї допомоги
Олег Корнійчук налаштований рішуче зараз
він збирає пожертви на придбання
портативних інкубаторів щоб під час
російських бомбардувань забирати
немовлят в укриття
його рішучість і відданість своїм
пацієнтам дійсно вражає
любити і бути коханим Ось у чому сенс
життя і за десятиліття що минули з часом
написання цієї романтичної балади наше
колективне визнання любові та її
можливостей стає все більш відкритим Та
інклюзивним це стосується і цієї молодої
пари з Польщі Войтика та Агати молодят
із надзвичайної історією кохання вони
відверто розповідають про своє
повсякденне життя в Інстаграмі на
сторінці життя на колесах руйнуючи
стереотипи що існують навколо кохання
що робити з реліквіями минулого які
віджили свій вік деякі з них можна
знести але інші і як ця культова
британська електростанція в Лондоні
просто занадто величні що бути
зруйнованими барі згадує зі своїм сином
старі добрі часи коли він працював тут
молодим електриком колись вона
обслуговувала Букінгемський палац та
будівлі парламенту її навіть увічнили у
фільмі Хічкока Але у 1983 році
електростанція батерсі була виведена з
експлуатації і перетворилася на руїну
зараз Іскра знову запалала на річці
Темзі це гігант обслуговує нову групу
клієнтів
храм індустріальної епохи та одна з
найвідоміших пам'яток Лондона
електростанція батерсі
[музика]
але після того як на початку
1980-х відключили останній генератор
колишній електростанція прийшла у
занепад
десятиліттями лондонці побоювалися за
свою пам'ятку але зараз вона знову
відкрита і відвідувачі стікаються туди
щоб по-новому відкрити для себе культову
будівлю
пол наприклад залазив у руїни потайки
уночі Я сподіваюся що приміщення
зберегли частину своєї грандіозності і
розмірів а також трохи ну не знаю Я
трохи хвилююся що певні комерційні
аспекти забрали частину магії цього
місця
своїм відродженням електростанція
завдячує міжнародним інвесторам які
зробили її серцем нового елітного району
уперше за 43 роки на станцію повернувся
і в барі Він привіз із собою сина у
молодості він працював тут електриком
це трохи хвилює
так хвилює
О Боже неймовірні відчуття
це повертає всі спогади
тоді як розповідає барій своєму синові
електроенергія вироблялася за допомогою
вугілля та пари
дим і пара що піднімалися з труб сприяли
виникненню знаменитого Лондонського
туману спалювали тут і всілякі інші
сміття яке потрібно було утилізувати
наприклад прострочені банкноти і ці
пачки банкнот не завжди згорали повністю
Баррі каже що це пояснює чому деякі з
його колег несподівано з'являлися у дуже
дорогих костюмах у своїй вихідні
я до того що раніше Вони робили так щоб
горали лише зовнішня сторона тому що
гроші були щільно упаковані ззовні вони
обгорали але всередині гроші знаєте були
абсолютно цілими їх неможливо було
відстежити таке от оригінальне
відмивання грошей на електростанції
батерсою
пол досліджує іншу сторону старого залу
тут збереглися деякі залишки колишньої
архітектури
[музика]
ось отак як я очікував трохи суму
Насправді немає вже того простору який
був раніше усе заставлено магазинами і
це тепер схожий на будь-який торговий
центр у будь-якому іншому місці
сьогодні електростанція батерсі це храм
грошей споживання та розкоші барі
потрібно трохи звикнути до цього
для мене це був дім Розумієте як я вже
казав раніше це була моя сім'я це дійсно
була моя сім'я ця будівля там на горі та
диспетчерська
Так коли ти думаєш про те що ти під
контролем було 250 МВт потужності що ти
контролював значну частину західного
Лондона уся Влада була в твоїх руках
так це дійсно неймовірні Відчуття і це
було приголомшливо справді дивовижно
диспетчерська де працював барі була
серцем електростанції сьогодні тут
проводять розкішні приватні заходи а для
звичайних відвідувачів вона закрита так
у певному сенсі мені сумно що я не можу
потрапити до диспетчерської Можливо
колись мені вдасться пробратися туди
потайки
величезна диспетчерська була побудована
повністю у стилі арт-деко 1930-х років
центр потужності тих часів коли
індустріальні будівлі що мали відтінок
сакральності
тим часом пол знайшов ще одну реліквію
тих часів меншу диспетчерську яка зараз
стала Баром із шампанським
пол проникав сюди коли електростанція
була руїною і фотографував те що
знаходив
тут цілий бар якщо не брати цього до
уваги то все майже так само це дійсно
Круто І вони дуже гарно все зберегли це
добре
колишній храм промислової революції з
червоної цегли перенесений у XXI
століття
трансформується і навколишній район барі
майже нічого не впізнає поки не
знаходить Пап який він ще пам'ятає
[музика]
є відчуття смутку Я думаю що не тільки
за баттерсі але за Лондона в цілому
завог де я народився будь-який місцем це
зараз багаті райони знаєте і це було
питанням часу коли з'їдять батерси і
вони це зробили
але Пол каже що є й позитивні сторони це
також дуже добре як на мене що кожен
може побачити його зараз а не тільки
Божевільні Авантюристи які вдираються
всередину Ви знаєте це дійсно красива
річ яку варто побачити це дуже
магнетична будівля і тому я радий що
вона зберігається люди можуть прийти її
побачити але є легке відчуття втрати
чогось іншого чого вже не повернути
можливо електростанція батерсі і
втратила частину своєї величі Опинившись
між розкішними житловими комплексами але
стара ікона все що стоїть і в Лондоні
охопленому багатством цьому варто радіти
[музика]
молитва за мир на санктуарі у Франції
територія навколо столиці Франції Парижа
справжній плавильний котел релігійний та
іноді Віру використовують як інструмент
для розколу суспільства Але в цьому
передмісті Парижа мусульмани та іудеї
приймають свою відмінності багато
конфесійний район бюссі сан-джорж
розпочав проект спрямований на сприяння
діалогу та толерантності проект під
назвою еспланада релігій створює простір
для покоління людей різних віросповідань
і їхні двері відкриті для всіх
Домінік фонтен готується до церковної
служби він католицький священник у бювці
сен-джорж
серед гостей Клод віндіж та бернаржа
усіх їх пов'язує спільна робота над
незвичайним проектом
Я радий вітати вас сьогодні і радий що у
вас тут так багато
християни іудеї та буддисти моляться
разом нічого незвичайного для BBC Сан
Джорджа
це дуже зворушливо що вони приходять до
церкви це свідчить про їхню дружбу
Це наче весь світ збирається разом
цей міжконфесійний день показує нам що є
інший спосіб жити разом у цьому світі
які стає все більш хаотичним
Жорж типове французьке передмістя
розташоване за 30 кілометрів на схід від
Парижа половина його 30-тисячного
населення має міграційне минуле і в
цьому немає нічого незвичайного але
еспланада релігій - це особливе місце
єдине у своєму роді в Європі
кожна з основних світових релігій має
тут свій молитовний будинок
[музика]
ми можемо бути справжніми сусідами на
одній вулиці
[музика]
запросила усіх до буддійського храму на
чай такі зустрічі вони проводять вже 10
років всі релігії за одним столом разом
працюють спілкуються відзначають
найважливіші релігійні свята
і які всі молитовні будинки у Франції
фінансуються лише за рахунок пожертв
не Ода показує відвідувачам храм це одна
з перших будівель на еспланаді релігія
також Один із найбільших буддійських
центрів за межами Азії
сама неуда приїхала до Франції як
біженка з В'єтнаму
моє сусіди тут стали друзями не важливо
якої вони релігії ми живемо як брати і
сестри як одна велика родина
наша наступна зупинка синагога тимчасово
розміщена в контейнері Заходьте Клод
віндіш президент місцевої єврейської
громади
дуже радий вітати вас у нашій маленькій
ціновою
Він показує відвідувачам найсвятіший
артефакт синагоги сувій Тори багато з
того про що розповідається в турі
перегукується з їхніми власними
релігіями
у всіх нас є схожі теми однакові правила
наприклад не вбий
це є в коранією Євангеліє і вторі
це є в усіх релігіях
з ним погоджується і Голова місцевої
ісламської громади фарид чауі
після руйнівних нападів ісламістів у
2015 році він відіграє тут особливу роль
друзі зробили мені честь попросив щоб
виступити адже справа стосувалася
мусульман і ми раптово опинилися у
центрі уваги я публічно засудив напади
категорично і звернувся із закликом до
усіх нас жити разом у злагоді
мечеть одне з найпопулярніших місць
поклоніння в бюссі сан-джорж
велична і проста водночас Як і всі інші
релігійні споруди тут вона відкрита для
всіх
і ця відкритість сформувала місцевий
політичний клімат
всіх релігій тут має вплив на громаду
екстреміські партії такі як національно
об'єднання лепена отримує тут на 10%
менше голосів ніж у сусідніх містах
еспланада релігії ще не завершена
індуїстський храми ще тільки
проектується нова синагога має бути
збудована поруч із мечею
фарит чауі збирав пожертви на проект А
зокрема і від мусульман
звісно я запитав дозволу у Клода і він
сказав так уперед я Взявся за справу
Це мене дуже зворушило
і все це саме так і відбулося справді це
і є Дружба щось дійсно особливе
чудовий приклад для наслідування у
новому році Дякуємо що приєдналися до
нас сьогодні сподіваємося вам
сподобалась наша програма до зустрічі
українською мовою озвучено центром медіа
ініціатив Київ 2023 рік
[музика]